Once upon a time there
was a lovely princess.
But she had an enchantment upon her
of a fearful sort,
which could only be broken
by Love's first kiss.
She was locked away in a castle
guarded by a terrible fire breathing dragon.
Many brave knights had attempted to free her
from this dreadful prison, but none prevailed.
She waited in the dragon's keep in the highest
room of the tallest tower for her true love
and true love's first kiss.
Like that's ever going to happen.
What a loony.
Somebody once told me
The world is gonna roll me
I ain't the sharpest tool in the shed
She was looking kind of dumb
With her finger and her thumb
In the shape of
an "L" on her forehead
Well, the years start coming
And they don't stop coming
Fed to the rules and
I hit the ground running
Didn't make sense
not to live for fun
Your brain gets smart
but your head gets dumb
So much to do, so much to see
So what's wrong with
taking the back streets
You'll never know
if you don't go
You'll never shine
if you don't glow
Hey now, you're an all star
Get your game on, go play
Hey now, you're a rock star
Get the show on, get paid
And all that glitters is gold
Only shooting stars
break the mold
It's a cool place and
they say it gets colder
You're bundled up now
Wait 'til you get older
But the meteor men beg to differ
Judging by the hole
in the satellite picture
The ice we skate
is getting pretty thin
The water's getting warm
So you might as well swim
My world's on fire,
how about yours
That's the way I like it
and I never get bored
--Beware--
Hey now, you're an all star
Get your game on, go play
Hey now, you're a rock star
Get the show on, get paid
All that glitters is gold
Only shooting stars
break the mold
Hey now, you're an all star
Get your game on, go play
--Stay out--
Hey now, you're a rock star
Get the show on, get paid
All that glitters is gold
Only shooting stars
break the mold
I think he's in there.
All right. Lets get it!
Hold on.
Do you know what
that thing can do to you?
Yeah. He'll grind your bones
for his bread.
Well actually
that would be a giant.
Now Ogres, huh,
they are much worse.
They'll make a suit
from your freshly peeled skin.
They'll chew your livers,
squeeze the jelly from your eyes.
Actually,
it's quite good on toast.
Back, back beast, back!
I warned you!
Right.
This is the part,
where you run away.
Yeah!
And stay out.
Wanted.
Fairytale creatures.
Right, this one is full.
Take it away.
Give me that.
Your fine days are over.
-25 pieces of silver for the witch.
Next.
-Come on.
Sit down there!
And be quiet!
This cage is so small.
You wouldn't turn me in.
I'll never be stubborn again.
I can change.
Please, give me another chance.
Oh, shut up!
Next.
What do we got?
This little wooden puppet.
I'm not a puppet,
I'm a real boy.
Five shillings for the possessed toy.
Take it away.
No! Please, don't let them do it!
Next. What do you got?
Well, I've got a talking donkey!
Right.
Well that's good for ten schillings,
if you can prove it.
Oh, go ahead fella.
Well?
He's just a li...,
just a little nervous.
He's really quite a chatterbox.
You boneheaded donkey!
That's it.
I have heard enough. Guards!
No, no, he talks, he does!
I can talk.
I love to talk.
I've talked to...
Get her out of my sight!
-No, no, I swear!
Hey, I can fly.
-He can fly! -He can fly!
He can talk!
-That's right, fool!
Now I'm a flying,
talking donkey!
You might have seen house fly,
maybe even a super fly.
But I bet you ain't
never seen a donkey fly!
Seize him!
Get him! This way! Hurry!
You there. Ogre.
-I.
By the order of lord Farquaad.
I am authorized to place you
both under arrest.
And transport you to a designated
resettlement facility.
Oh really?
You and what army?
Can I say something to you?
Listen, you were really, really something,
back there. Incredible.
Are you talking to...
...me?
Yes, I was talking to you.
Can I just tell you that you were
really great back there
with those guards.
They thought that was all over there.
And then you showed up and BAM.
There was tripping
on over themselves like babes in the woods.
That really made me
feel good to see that.
Oh, that's great.
Really.
Man, it's good to be free.
Now, why don't you go celebrate your freedom
with your own friends?
But I...
I don't have any friends.
And I'm not going out there by myself.
Hey wait a minute.
I have a great idea...
I'll stick with you.
You and me in green fighting machine.
Together we'll scare the spin
if anybody crosses us.
Oh, a, that was really scary.
Maybe you don't mind me saying.
If that don't work,
your breath will certainly
do the job done, 'cause...
you definitively need some
tic-tac or something,
'cause your breath stinks!
Man you've ???  my note!
Just like the time...
...and then I ate some rotten berries.
Man I had some strong gases leaking
out of my but that day.
Why are you following me?
I'll tell you why.
'Cause I'm all alone,
there is no one here, beside me.
My problems have all gone.
There's no one to derive me.
But you got to have free ...
-Stop singing!
Well, it's no wonder,
you don't have any friends.
Wow! Only a true friend
would be that truly honest.
Listen! Little donkey.
Take a look at me! What am I?
Ah...
...really tall?
No! I'm an Ogre.
You know, grab your torch and pitchforks.
Doesn't that bother you?
Nope.
Really?
-Really really.
Oh?
Man, I like you.
What's your name?
Ah..., Shrek.
Shrek?!
But do you know,
what I like about you, Shrek?
You've got that kind of:
"I don't care what nobody thinks of me" thing.
I like that, I respect that, Shrek.
You're all right.
Uh, look at that.
Who would wanna live in
a place like that?
That would be my home.
Oh, it is lovely. Just beautiful.
You know you're quite a decorator.
It's amazing what you did
with such a modest budget.
I like that boulder.
That is a nice boulder.
I guess, you don't
entertain much, do you?
I like my privacy.
You know I do to.
That's another thing, we have in common.
Like I hate it when you got somebody
in your face.
You try to give them a hint
and they won't leave.
And then there's that big occurred silence,
you know?
Can I stay with you?
-What?
Can I stay with you,
please.
Of course!
-Really?
No.
-Please! I don't want to go back there.
You don't know how is like
to be considered a freak.
Well..., maybe you do.
But that's why we have to stick together!
You got to let me stay!
Please! Please!
OK, OK.
-But one night only.
-Huh, thank you!
A, what are you do... No!
This is going to be fun.
We can stay up late,
swap the manly stories.
And in the morning...
I'll make waffles.
Where do I sleep?
Outside!
Oh, a, I guess that's cool.
I don't know you and
you don't know me...
... so I guess, outside is best, you know.
Here I go.
Good night.
I do like that half door.
I'm a donkey all alone outside.
Sit by myself outside, I guess.
I'm all alone,
there's no one here beside me.
-I thought, I told you to stay outside.
-I am outside.
Well James. This is far from the farm,
but what choice do we have?
It's not home, but we'll do just fine.
What a lovely bed.
-Got you!
I found some cheese.
Awful stuff.
-Is that you Gordon?
-How did you know?
Enough!
What are you doing in my house?
Oh, no, no, no...
Death prod off the table!
Where would we supposed to put her.
The bed's taken.
What?
I live in a swamp.
I've put up signs.
I'm a terrifying Ogre!
What do I have to do,
to get a little privacy?
Oh, no! No, no!
What are you doing in my swamp?
All right, get out of here. All of you.
Move it! Come on, let's go.
And hurry up, hurry up.
No, no, not there. Not there!
Hey don't look at me.
I didn't invite them.
Oh gosh, no one invited us.
-What?
We were forced to come here.
-By who?
Lord Farquaad.
He hoofed and he bopped
and signed a conviction notice.
All right.
Who knows where this
Farquaad guy is?
Oh I do.
I know where he is.
Does anyone else
know where to find him?
-Anyone at all?
-Me. -Anyone?
Oh pick me,
I know! Me, me.
Ok, fine.
Attention all fairy tale things!
Do not get comfortable.
Your welcome is officially warned up.
In fact.
I'm gonna see this guy Farquaad right now
and get all off my land
and back where you came from.
You.
You're coming with me.
All right.
That's what I like to hear, man.
Shrek and Donkey,
two stubborn friends off on a
world and big city adventure. I love it.
I'm on road again.
Sing with me Shrek!
I'm on road again...
What did I say about singing?
-Can I whistle?
-No.
-Well, can I hummer?
-All right.
That's enough.
He's ready to talk.
Run, run, run as fast as you can,
you can't catch me.
I'm the gingerbread man.
You're a monster.
I'm not a monster here. You are.
You and the rest of that fairytale trash,
poisoning my perfect world.
-Now tell me! Where are the others?
-Eat me.
I've tried to be fair to you, creatures.
Now my patience has reached its end!
-Tell me! Or I'll...
-No, no, not the buttons.
Not gumdrop buttons.
All right! Who's hiding them?
Ok, I'll tell you.
-Do you know the muffin-man?
The muffin-man?
-The muffin-man.
Yes, I know the muffin-man.
Who lives on Proully lane?
-Well, she's married to the muffin-man.
-The muffin-man!
-She's married to the muffin-man.
My lord! We found it.
Well then, what are you waiting for?
Bring it in.
Magic mirror.
Don't tell him anything!
Evening.
Mirror, mirror on the wall.
Is this not the most
perfect kingdom of them all?
Well, technically,
you're not a king.
Ah..., felonious.
-You were saying.
-What I mean is a...
...you're not a king, yet.
But you can become one.
All you have to do,
is marry a princess.
Go on.
So, just sit back
and relax my lord,
because it's time for you
to meet today's eligible bachelorettes.
And here they are.
Bachelorette number one is a mentally abused
shedding from a kingdom far, far away.
She likes sushi
and hot tubbing anytime.
Her hobbies include cooking and
cleaning for two evil sisters.
Please welcome... Cinderella.
Bachelorette number two is a
cape wearing girl from a land of fantasy.
Although she lives with seven other man,
she is not easy.
Just kiss hers dead frozen lips
and find out what a live wife she is.
Come on.
Give it up for... Show-white.
And last but certainly not least.
Bachelorette number three
is a fire-red head,
from a dragon guarded castle,
surrounded by a hot boiling lava.
But don't let that cool you off.
She's a loaded pistol who likes
Piña Coladas and getting caught in the rain.
Yours for the rescuing,
Princess Fiona.
So will it be, bachelorette number one?
Bachelorette number two?
Or bachelorette number three?
-Two... -Three! -Two!
One. No, no, no.
Three.
Pick number three my lord.
Ok, ok. Number three.
Lord Farquaad. You've chosen...
princess Fiona.
She's nice. Fiona.
She's perfect.
All I have to do is just find someone...
But I probably should mention little thing
that happens at night...
-I'll do it!
-Yes, but after sunset...
Silence!
I will make this princess Fiona my queen.
And Duloc will finally have the perfect king!
Captain! Assemble your finest man.
We're going to have a tournament!
That's it, that's,
right there, that's Duloc.
I've told you I'll find it.
So. That must be lord Farquaad's castle.
Aha, that's the place.
Do you think maybe he's
compensating for something.
Hey, hey wait up Shrek!
-Hey, you!
-No, no!
Wait a second.
Look, I'm not gonna eat you.
I just...
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
Where is everybody?
Hey look at this.
"Welcome to Du-Duloc,
such a perfect town."
"Here we have some rules,
let us lay them down."
"Don't make waves,
stay in the line,"
"and we'll get along fine.
Duloc is the perfect place."
"Please keep off the grass,
shine your shoes wipe your ... face."
"Duloc is...
Duloc is..."
"Duloc is the perfect town."
Wow!
-Let's do that again.
-No. no.
All right.
You're going the right way for smack bottom.
Sorry about that.
That champion should have the honor,
no, no...
...the privilege to go forth
and rescue the lovely princess Fiona
from the firing keep of the dragon.
If for any reason
the winner is unsuccessful,
the first runner up
will take his place.
And so on,
and so forth.
Some of you may die,
but it's a sacrifice
I'm willing to make.
Applause.
Let the tournament begin.
What is that?
Ugh, it's hideous.
Oh, that's not very nice.
It's just a donkey.
Indeed.
Knights! New plan.
The one, who kills the Ogre,
will be named champion.
Go about him.
Oh, hey. Now, come on.
Can't we just settle this over a pint?
No?
All right then.
Come on.
I don't give a damn
about my reputation
You're living in the past,
it's a new generation
Hey, a girl can do what she wants to do
And that's what I'm gonna do
And I don't give a damn
about my bad reputation
Oh no
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
Not me
Me, me, me, me, me, me
Hey Shrek! Let me, let me!
And I don't give a damn
about my reputation
I never said I wanted
to improve my station
And I'm only feeling good
when I'm having fun
And I don't have to please no one
--The chair--!
And I don't give a damn
about my bad reputation
--Give him the chair--!
Oh no
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
Not me
Me, me, me, me, me, me
Oh no
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
Not me
Me, me, me, me, me, me
Thank you.
Thank you, very much.
I'm here until Thursday.
Try to view!
Shall I give the order sir?
No. I have a better idea.
People of Duloc.
I give you our champion!
What?
Congratulation, Ogre.
You've won the honor of embarking
on a great and noble quest.
Quest? I'm already on a quest.
A quest to get my swamp back!
-Your swamp?
-Yeah, my swamp!
Where you dumped those
fairytale creatures.
Indeed.
All right Ogre,
I'll make you a deal.
Go on this quest for me and
I'll give you your swamp back.
Exactly the way it was?
Down to the last slime
covered toad stone.
-And the squatters?
-As good as gone.
What kind of quest?
Ok, let me get this straight!
We gonna go find the dragon
and rescue a princess just so Farquaad
will give you back the swamp,
which you only don't have,
'cause he filled it with full of freaks
on the first place.
-Is that about right?
-You know what?
Maybe there is a good reason,
donkeys shouldn't talk.
I don't get it Shrek.
Why didn't you just pull
some old Ogre stuff on them?
You know, ??? .
Grab his bones to make a bridge.
You know the whole Ogre trick.
Oh, you know what.
Maybe I could have decapitated
an entire village and
put their heads on plate.
Got a knife, cut open their spleens
and drink their fluids.
Does that sound good to you?
A, no, not really, no.
For your information,
there is a lot more to Ogres
than people think.
-Example.
-Example?
OK, A-a-m, Ogres are like onions.
-They stink?
-Yes, no.
-Or, they make you cry.
-No.
Oh, you leave them out on the sun
and they get all brown
and start to spread little white hairs?
No! Layers!
Onions have layers.
Ogres have layers.
You get it?
We both have layers.
Oh, you both have layers.
You know not everybody likes onions.
Cake! Everybody loves cakes.
Cakes have layers.
I don't care
what everyone likes.
Ogres are not like cakes.
You know what else everyone likes? Paffe.
Have you ever met a person and you say:
"Hey, let's get some paffe" and
they say I don't like paffe.
Paffe is delicious.
No! You tensed, irritating,
miniature piece of burden.
Ogres are like onions.
End of story.
Bye, bye.
See you later.
Paffe is maybe the most delicious thing
on the whole damn planet.
You know I think I've preferred your humming.
Do you have a tissue or something,
'cause I'm making a mess.
Just the word paffe
has made me start sliming
Why, Shrek, did you do that?
Man you got to warn somebody
before you just crack one off.
My mouth was opened and everything.
Believe me donkey, if it was me,
you'd be dead.
It's brimstone.
We must be getting close.
Yeah, right, brimstone.
Don't be talking about brimstone.
I know what I smell and was no brimstone.
And they don't come of a stone neither.
Sure it's big enough,
but look at the location.
Oh, Shrek, remember when you said
that Ogres have layers?
Oh, yeah.
Well, I have a confession to make.
Donkeys don't have layers.
We wear our fear right
out there in our sleeves.
Wait a second.
Donkeys don't have sleeves.
-You know what I mean.
-Oh, you can't tell me you're afraid of highs.
No, I'm just a little uncomfortable of being
on a rickety bridge over boiling lake of lava!
Come on donkey,
I'm right here beside you. Ok?
For emotional support.
We'll just tackle this thing together
one little baby step after time.
-Really?
-Really really.
Ok. That makes me feel so much better.
Just keep moving and don't look down.
Don't look down, don't look down.
Shrek! I'm looking down!
I can't do this.
Just let me off right now, please.
-But you're already half way.
-Yeah, but I know that half is safe.
Ok, fine. I don't have time for this.
You go back.
Shrek, no, wait.
Don't do that!
Oh, I'm sorry. Do what?
-Oh. This?
-Yes, that!
Yes, yes. Do it. OK.
-No, Shrek!
-I'm doing it.
I'm gonna die.
Shrek, I'm gonna die.
That will do Donkey, that will do.
Cool.
So where is this fire
breathing pain in the neck anyway?
Inside. Waiting for us to rescue her.
I was talking about the dragon Shrek.
-Are you afraid?
-No, but shhhhh.
Oh, good. Me neither.
Because there's nothing wrong with being afraid.
Here's a..., something
responsible of the situation.
Not to mention dangerous situation.
And there's dragon that breathes fire.
I'm sure he's meaner
than a cow or anything,
but they scare.
You know what I mean.
I'm sure he's heavier than a cow...
Donkey. Two things. Ok?
Shut, up.
Now go over there and see
if you can find any stairs.
Stairs? I thought we were looking for the princess.
The princess will be up the stairs in the
highest room in the tallest tower.
What makes you think she'll be there?
I read it in a book once.
Cool. You handle the dragon,
I'll handle the stairs.
Oh, I'll find those stairs.
I'll ???. That's right.
Those stairs won't know
which way they go.
The drafting stairs, ???
Don't mess with me.
I'm the stair master.
I'm master of the stairs.
I wish I had a stair right here
right here now, I'd step all over it.
Well, at least we know where the princess is.
-But where is the...
-Dragon!
Donkey, look out!
Got you.
Oh, what large teeth you have.
I mean, white sparkling teeth.
You probably hear this
all the time from your food, but
you must bleach yourself,
because that is one dazzling smile
you got there.
And do I detect the hint
of minty freshness?
And you know what else?
You're a girl dragon. Oh, sure.
I mean 'course you're a girl dragon,
'cause you're just ricking
the feminine beauty out.
What's the matter with you?
Do you have something in your eye?
Man, I'd really love to stay, but you know
I'm a asthmatic and
I don't know if we would worked out.
You'd be blowing smoke and stuff.
Shrek!
No, Shrek! Shrek!
-Wake up!
-What?
Are you princess Fiona?
I am.
Awaiting a knight
so bold as to rescue me.
Oh, that's nice. Now let's go.
But wait, sir knight.
This be our first meeting.
Should it not be wonderful,
romantic moment?
Yeah. Sorry lady there's no time.
Hey, what are you doing?
You know, you should
sweep me off my feet.
Out through the window and down
the rope by to your valued steed.
You've had a lot of time to plan this,
haven't you?
Uh-um.
But we have to sing
through this moment.
You can recite a poem to me.
A ballad, a sonnet, a libretto,
or something.
I don't think so.
Well, can I at least know
the name of my champion?
Shrek.
So, Shrek.
I pray that you take this favor
as a token of my gratitude.
Thanks.
-You didn't slay the dragon?
-It's so much to do this. Now, come on!
But this isn't right.
You torture him,
sword drawn better fight.
That's what all the other knights did.
Yeah. Right before they burst in the flame.
That's not the point.
Wait. Where are you going?
Exit is over there.
Well, I have to save my ass.
What kind of knight are you?
One of a kind.
...rush into a physical relationship.
I'm not that emotionally ready
for a commitment of a this  magnitude.
That was the word I was looking for.
Magnitude.
Hey, that is unwanted physical contact.
Hey, what are you doing?
Ok, ok, let's just back up a little and
take this one step at the time.
I mean, we really should
get to know each other first,
you know what am I saying.
As friends, maybe even as pen pals.
Hey don't do that.
That's my tail.
That's ma personal tail.
And you're going to tear it off....
I don't give permission to
Hey, what you want to do that
Oh, no. No!
-It talks?!
-Yeah. It's getting to shut up,
that's a trick.
Ok, you two.
Head for the exit.
I'll take care of the dragon.
Ruuuuun!
You did it.
You rescued me.
Amazing, you're wonderful.
You're a ...
...a little unorthodox I admit, but
by deed is great
and by heart is pure.
I'm entirely in your debt.
And where would a brave knight be
without his noble steed.
I hope you heard that.
She called me a noble steed.
She thinks I'm a steed.
The battle is won.
You may remove your helmet good sir knight.
-Aah, no.
-Why not?
I have helmet hair.
Please.
I wouldst look upon the face of my rescuer.
Oh, no, you wouldn't, dust.
But, how will you kiss me?
What? That wasn't in a job description.
-Maybe it's a perk?
-No. It's destiny.
You must know how it goes.
A princess locked in a tower and beset
by a dragon is rescued by a brave knight.
And then they share
true love's first kiss.
With Shrek? You think, wait...
...you think Shrek is your true love?
Well, yes.
You think that Shrek is your true love.
What is so funny?
Let's just say,
I'm not your type, ok?
Of course you are.
You're my rescuer.
Now, now remove your helmet.
Look.
I really don't think this is a good idea.
-Just take off the helmet.
-I'm not going to.
-Take it off!
-No!
-Now!
-Ok, easy.
As you command your highness.
You're an Ogre.
Oh, you were expecting Prince Charming.
Well, yes, actually.
Oh no. This is all wrong.
You're not supposed to be an Ogre.
Princess, I was sent to rescue you
by lord Farquaad, ok?
He's the one, who wants to marry you.
Well, then why didn't he come to rescue me?
Good question.
You should ask him that,
when we get there.
But I have to be rescued
by my true love.
Not by some Ogre and his pet.
Well so much for noble steed.
Look princess.
You're not making my job any easier.
Well I'm sorry,
but your job is not my problem.
You can tell lord Farquaad
that if he wants to rescue me properly,
I'll be waiting for him right here.
Hey, I'm no ones messenger boy,
all right?
-I'm a delivery boy.
-You wouldn't dare.
-You coming donkey?
-Put me down!
Yeah, I'm right behind you.
Put me down
or you will suffer the consequences.
This is not dignified.
Put me down.
Ok, here's another question.
Let's say that a woman 'digged' you,
but you don't really like her, that way.
Now, how you let her down real easy,
so her feelings aren't hurt?
But you don't get burned to a crisp neither.
How do you do this?
Just tell her, she's not your true love.
Everyone knows it what happens
when you find...
Hey! The sooner we get to Duloc, the better.
Oh, yeah.
You gonna love it there princess.
It's beautiful.
And what of my groom to be, lord Farquaad.
What's he like?
Well, let me put it this way,
princess.
Men of Farquaad's stature
are in short supply.
Oh no, Shrek. There are those
who think little of him.
Stop it. Stop it, both of you.
You know, you're just jealous
that you can never measure up
to a great ruler
like lord Farquaad.
Yeah. Well maybe you're right princess.
But I'd like you do that measuring
when you see him tomorrow
Tomorrow?
It will take that long?
-Shouldn't we stop to make camp?
-No. That would take longer.
We can keep going.
But there are robbers in the woods.
Whoa, time out Shrek.
Camp is definitely something that sounds good.
Hey. Come on.
I'm scarier than anything
we're gonna see in this forest.
I need to find somewhere to camp, now!
Hey, over here.
Shrek, we can do better than that.
Now, I don't think this is decent for princess.
No, no, it's perfect.
It just needs a few homey touches.
Homey touches? Like what?
A door.
Well, gentleman I'll be d..., good night.
Do you want me to come in
and read you a bedtime story,
'cause I will...
I said good night!
Shrek! What are you doing?
I just..., you know...
Oh, come on,
I was just kidding.
And that one,
that's Throwback.
The only Ogre to ever spit
over three wheat fields.
Right. Yeah.
Hey, can you tell my future from these stars?
Well, the stars don't tell the future, Donkey.
They tell stories. Look.
There's Blodna, the "Flatulent"
You can guess what he is famous for.
All right.
Now I know you're making this up.
No. Look. There he is
and there's the group of hunters
running away from his stag.
Man, there ain't nothing,
but a bunch of little dots.
You know donkey,
sometimes things are more than they appear.
Forget it.
Hey Shrek.
What are you gonna do
when we get our swamp back,
anyway?
-Our swamp? -You know.
When we're through rescuing the princess
and all that stuff.
We? Donkey, there is no we.
There's no our.
There's just me and my swamp.
And the first thing I'm gonna do,
is build a ten foot wall around my land.
You cut me deep Shrek, you cut me real deep just now.
You know, what I think?
I think this whole wall thing
is just a way to keep somebody out.
No, do you think?
-Are you hiding something?
-Never mind Donkey.
Oh, this is another one of those onion things,
isn't it?
No. This is one of those drop it
and leave it alone things.
-Why don't you want to talk about it?
Why do you want to talk about it?
-Oh, Why you block?
-I'm not blocking.
-Oh yes you are.
-Donkey, I'm warning you.
-Who are you trying to keep out?
Just tell me that Shrek. Who?
Everyone, ok?
-Oh, now we're getting somewhere.
-Oh, for 'the love of pit'.
Hey, what's your problem Shrek?
What do you got against the whole world anyway?
Look. I'm not the one
with the problem, ok?
It's the world that seems
to have a problem with me.
People take one look at me and go:
AAA... Help! Run!
A big stupid ugly Ogre.
They judge me,
before they even know me.
That's why I'm better off alone.
You know what? When we met,
I didn't think you're just a big stupid, ugly Ogre.
Yeah, I know.
So, a... Are there any donkeys up there?
Well, there's a Cabby.
The small and annoying.
Ok, ok. I see him, now.
Big shining one, right there.
That one, over there?
That's the moon.
Again. Show me again.
Mirror, mirror, show her to me.
Show me the princess.
Perfect.
Yeah. You know I like like that.
Oh come on baby...
-Donkey. Wake up.
-What? -Wake up.
Morning. How do you like your eggs?
-Good morning princess.
-What's all this about?
You know, we kind of got of
to a bad start yesterday
and I wanted to make it up to you.
I mean, after all,
you did rescue me.
Thanks.
Well, eat up.
We've got a big day ahead of us.
-Shrek!
-What? It's a compliment.
Better out than in
I always say.
But that's no way to behave
in front of a princess.
-Thanks.
-She's as nasty as you are.
You know.
You're not exactly what I've expected.
Well, maybe you shouldn't judge people
before you get to know them.
La liberté.
Princess!
What are you doing?
Be still mon shery,
for I am your saviour.
And I am rescuing you from this green
...beast.
Hey! That's my princess.
Go find your own.
Please, monster.
Can't you see I'm a little busy here?
Look, pal.
I don't know who you think you are.
Oh, of course.
How rude that was.
Please, let me introduce myself.
Oh merry men!
Ta, da, da, da, da, da, whoo
I steal from the rich
and give to the needy
He takes a wee percentage,
but I'm not greedy
I rescue pretty damsels,
man, I'm good
What a guy, ha-ha, Monsieur Hood
Break it down
I like an honest fight
and a saucy little maid
What he's basically saying is he likes to
get...paid
So, when an ogre in the bush
grabs a lady by the tush
That's bad, that's bad,
that's bad, that's bad
When a beauty's with a beast
it makes me awfully mad
He's mad, he's really mad
Now I'll take my blade and
ram it through your heart
Keep your eyes on me, boys,
'Cause I'm about to staaar-
Man, that was annoying.
Oh, you little...
Shall we?
???all the forin???
Whoa, hold on, now.
Where did that come from?
-What?
-That. Back there. That was amazing.
Where did you learn that?
Well, when one lives alone one has to learn
these things in case there's a...
There is an arrow in your but.
What? Oh, would you look at that.
Oh, no... This is all my fault.
I'm so sorry.
-What's wrong?
-Shrek's hurt.
-Shrek's hurt? Shrek's hurt!
-Oh, no. Shrek's going to die.
-Donkey, I'm ok.
You can't do this to me Shrek.
I'm too young for you to die.
Keep your legs elevated.
Turn your head down.
-Does anyone know how to handle...
-Donkey! Calm down.
If you want to help Shrek,
run into woods and find me
a blue flower with red thorns.
Blue flower, red thorns. Ok, I'm on it.
Blue flower, red thorns.
Don't die Shrek.
And if you see a long tunnel,
stay away from the light!
-Donkey!
-Oh, yeah. Right. Blue flower, red thorns.
Blue flower, red thorns.
-What are the flowers for?
-For getting rid of Donkey.
Now, you hold still
and I'll yank this thing out.
-Hey! Easy with the yanking.
-I'm sorry, but it has to come out.
No, no. It's tender.
What you're doing here is the opposite...
-Don't move.
-Ok, look. Time out.
-Would you... Ok.
What do you propose we do?
Blue flower, red thorns.
This would be so much easier
if I wasn't colorblind.
Blue flower, red thorns.
Hold on, Shrek. I'm coming!
Not good.
Ok, ok, I can lose it.
It's just about it.
Nothing happened.
We were just a...
Look if you want to be alone,
all you had to do is ask, ok?
Oh, come on.
That's the last thing on my mind.
The princess here was just... Au!
Hey, what's that? Is that...
My beloved monster and me
We go everywhere together
Wearing a raincoat
that has four sleeves
Gets us through
all kinds of weather
She will always be
the only thing
That comes between me
and the awful sting
That comes from living in a world
that's so damn mean
There it is, princess.
-Your future awaits you.
-That's Duloc?
Yeah. I know. You'll shrink things
lord Farquaad is compensating for something,
which I think needs, he has a
I guess we better move on.
Sure, but Shrek...
-I'm worried about Donkey.
-What?
I mean. Look at him.
He doesn't look so good.
-What are you talking about? I'm fine.
-Well, that's what they always say.
And the next thing you know
you're on your back.
-Dead!
-You know she's right.
You look awful.
-Do you want to sit down?
-You know, I'll make you up some tea.
Well, I won't say nothing, but
I've got this twinge in my neck.
And if I turn my neck like this,
look. Au, see?
-He's hungry. I'll find us some dinner.
-I'll get the firewood.
Hey, where are you going?
Oh man, I can't feel my toes.
I don't have any toe!!!
I think I need a hug.
This is good.
This is really good.
-What is this?
-Wheat rat.
-Rotisserie style.
-No kidding.
-Oh, this is delicious.
-Well, they also great in stews.
Now, I don't mean to brag,
but I make a mean wheat rat stew.
I guess I'll be dining a little different
late tomorrow night.
Maybe you can come visit me
in the swamp sometime.
I'll cook all kinds of stuff for you.
Swamp toad soup, fish, eye tartar.
You name it.
I'd like that.
-Ah... , princess?
-Yes, Shrek?
I'm a.... I was wondering.
Are you... a...
Are you gonna eat that?
Man, isn't this romantic.
Just look at that sunset.
Sunset?! Oh, no. It's late.
It's very late.
-What?
-Wait a minute.
I see what's going on here.
You're afraid of the dark.
Aren't you?
Yes, yes. That's it.
That's, I'm terrified.
You know I'll better go inside.
But don't feel bad, princess.
I used to be afraid of the dark too.
Until... Hey, no, wait.
I'm still afraid of the dark.
-Good night.
Ahh. Now I really see what's going on here.
Oh, what are you talking about.
Hey I don't wanna even hear.
Look, I'm an animal and I got instincts.
And I know that you two are digging on each other.
I can feel it.
Oh, you're crazy.
I'm just bringing her back to Farquaad.
Oh, come on, Shrek.
Wake up and smell the pheromones.
Just go in there
and tell her how you feel.
There's nothing to tell.
Besides, even if I did tell her that...
well you know.
I'm not saying that I do,
'cause I don't.
She's a princess and I'm...
...an Ogre.
Yeah, an Ogre.
-Hey, where are you going?
-To get more firewood.
Princess. Princess Fiona?
Princess, where are you?
Princess?
It's very spooky in here
and are we playing little games.
-No, no.
-Help! Shrek! Shrek!
-No. -Shrek!
-It's ok. It's ok.
-What did you do with the princess?
-Donkey, shhh. I'm the princess.
-It's me, in this body.
-Oh my god. You ate the princess.
-Can you hear me?
-Donkey!
Listen, keep breathing.
I'll get you out of there!
Shrek! Shrek! Shrek!
This is me.
Princess? What happened to you?
You're a... different.
-I'm ugly, ok?
-Yeah.
Was it something that you ate?
'Cause I told Shrek those rats were a bad idea.
-You are what you eat, I say.
-No. I've been this way as long as I can remember.
What do you mean?
Look, I've never seen you like this before.
It only happens when the sun goes down.
By night one way, by day another.
This shall be the norm
until you find true love's first kiss.
Then, take love's true form...
-Oh, that's beautiful.
I didn't know you wrote poetry.
-It's a spell.
When I was a little girl,
a witch cast a spell on me.
Every night I become this.
This horrible ugly beast.
I was placed in a tower to await the day
when my true love would rescue me.
That's why I have to marry lord Farquaad tomorrow,
before the sun sets and he sees me, like this?
All right, all right. Calm down.
Look, it's not that bad. You're not that ugly.
Wait, wait, I'll not lie, you are ugly.
But you only look like this at night.
Shrek's ugly 24/7.
But Donkey, I'm a princess.
And this is not how a princess is meant to look.
Princess. How about if you don't marry Farquaad?
I have to.
Only my true love's kiss can brake the spell.
But you know, you're kind of an Ogre.
And Shrek...
Well you've got a lot in common.
Shrek?
Princess, I... How is it going first of all?
Good? Good for me to. I'm ok.
I saw this flower
and thought of you because it's pretty.
And, well, I don't really like it, but I thought
you may like it, because you're pretty.
But I like you anyway. A....
I'm in trouble.
Ok, here we go.
Who could ever love a piece so hideous and ugly?
Princess and ugly don't go together.
That's why I can't stay here with Shrek,
but only chance to live happily ever after
is to marry my true love.
Don't you see, Donkey? That's just how it has to be.
It's the only way to break the spell.
Well, at least you've got tell Shrek the truth.
No, no. You can't breathe the word.
No one must ever know.
What's the point of being unable to talk?
You got to keep secrets.
Promise you won't tell. Promise!
All right, all right.
I won't tell him. But you should.
You know, before this is over,
I'm going to need whole lot of serious therapies.
Look at my eye twitching.
I tell him,
I tell him not.
I tell him.
I tell him!
Shrek! Shrek! There's something I want ...
Shrek. Are you all right?
Perfect. Never been better.
I... There's something I have to tell you.
You don't have to tell me anything, princess.
I heard enough last night.
-You've heard what I said?
-Every word.
I thought you'd understand?
Oh, I understand!
Like you said, who could love a hideous, ugly beast!
-I thought that wouldn't matter to you.
-Yeah, well, it does.
Ah, right on time. Princess.
I brought you a little something.
What I missed?  What I missed?
-Princess Fiona.
-As promised. Now hand it over.
Very well, Ogre.
The deed to your swamp.
Cleared out as agreed. Take it and go.
Before I change my mind.
Forgive me princess for startling you,
but you startled me.
For I've never seen such a radiant beauty before.
-I am lord Farquaad.
-Lord Farquaad?
Oh, no, no... forgive me my lord for
I was just saying short... farewell.
Oh. That is so sweet.
You don't have to raise good manners on the Ogre.
-It's not like it has feelings.
-No. You're right. It doesn't.
Princess Fiona,
beautiful fair flawless Fiona,
I ask your hand in marriage.
Will you be the perfect bride for the perfect groom?
Lord Farquaad, I accept.
Nothing would make...
Excellent! I'll start the plans for tomorrow we wedd...
No! I mean I... Why wait?
Let's get married today.
Before sunset.
Oh, anxious are we?
You're right. The sooner, the better.
There's so much to do.
There is the camera,
the cake, the band, the guests...
Captain! Round up some guests.
Farewell Ogre.
Shrek, what are you doing?
You let her get away.
-Yeah, so what.
-Shrek. There's something about her that you don't know.
-I talked to her last night. She's...
-Yeah I know you talked to her last night.
You're great pal, aren't you?
Now, if you two are such good friends,
why didn't you follow her home?
-Shrek. I want to go with you.
-I told you, didn't I?
You're not coming home with me.
I live alone. My swamp, me and nobody else!
Understand? Nobody!
Especially useless, pathetic, annoying,
talking donkeys!
-But. I thought...
-Yeah. You know what?
You thought wrong.
Shrek.
I've heard there was a secret chord
That David played,
and it pleased the Lord
But you don't really care for music,
do you?
It goes like this:
the fourth, the fifth
The minor fall,
the major lift
The baffled king
composing Hallelujah
Hallelujah, Hallelujah
Baby, I've been here before
I know this room,
I've walked this floor
I used to live alone
before I knew you
I've seen your flag
on the marble arch
Love is not a victory march
It's a cold
and it's a broken Hallelujah
Hallelujah, Hallelujah
And all I ever learned from love
Was how to shoot at someone
who outdrew you
It's not a cry
you can hear at night
It's not somebody
who's seen the light
It's a cold
and it's a broken Hallelujah
Hallelujah, Hallelujah
Donkey?
What are you doing?
I was thinking of all the people,
you would recognize a wall
when you see one.
Well, yeah.
But the wall supposed to go around my swamp.
Not through it.
It is around your half.
See? That's your half and this is my half.
Oh, your half?
Yes, my half.
I helped rescue the princess.
I did half the work.
I get half the booty.
Now hand me that big old rock,
the one that looks like your head
-Back off!
-No. You back off!
-This is my swamp.
-Our swamp.
-Let go, Donkey!
-You let go!
-Stubborn jackass.
-Smelly Ogre.
Fine!
Hey, hey, come back here.
I'm not through with you, yet.
-Well, I'm through with you!
-Well, you know. You were always me, me, me.
Well, guess what? Now it's my turn!
So you just shut up and pay attention!
You are mean to me, you insult me,
you don't appreciate anything that I do!
You're always pushing me around
or pushing me away.
Oh, yeah?
Well, if I treated you so bad,
how come you came back?
Because that's what friends do.
They forgive each other!
Oh, yeah. You're right Donkey.
I forgive you for stabbing me in the back!
You're so wrapped up in layers, onion boy.
You're afraid of your own feelings.
-Go away.
-See? There you are, doing it again.
Just like you did it to Fiona.
And all she ever do, was like you.
Maybe even love you.
Love me?
She said I was ugly!
A hideous creature.
-I heard that you two were talking.
-She wasn't talking about you.
She was talking about...
...somebody else.
She wasn't talking about me?
Well then, who was she talking about?
No way, I'm not saying anything.
You won't listen to me, right? Right?
-Donkey.
-No!
Ok, look.
I'm sorry, all right?
I'm sorry.
I guess I am just a big stupid,
ugly Ogre.
Can you forgive me?
-Hey, that's the friends are for, right?
-Right.
-Friends?
-Friends.
So? What did Fiona said about me?
Why are you asking me for?
Why don't you just go ask her.
The wedding! We'll never make it in time!
Never fear! For where there is a will,
there is a way.
And I have a way.
Donkey?
-I guess this is just my act of magnetism.
-Oh, come here, you.
All right. All right.
Don't get all started.
No one likes kiss an ass.
All right, hop on.
Hold on tight.
I hadn't have a chance
to install seat belts, yet.
People of Duloc. We gather here today
to bear witness to reunion of our new king...
Excuse me.
Could you just skip ahead to "I do's"?
Go on.
Go ahead and have some fun,
if we need you, I'll whistle. How about that?
Shrek, wait, wait a minute.
You want to do this right, don't you?
-What are you talking about?
-It's the line, it's the line you got to wait for.
The priest is going to say:
"Speak now or forever hold your peace".
And that's where you say: "I object".
-I don't have time for this.
-Wait, wait. What are you doing? Listen to me!
Look, you love this woman, don't you?
-Yes.
-You want to hold her!
-Please her!
-Yes!
Then you got to,
got to try a little tenderness.
-The chicks love that romantic crap.
-All right. Cut it out.
When does this guy say the line?
We got to check it out.
And as so by the power vested in me...
What do you see?
-I now pronounce you...
-There they go!
-...he already said it.
-Oh, for 'the love of pit'.
I object!
Shrek?
Oh, now what does he want?
Hi, everyone.
Having a good time, aren't you?
I love Duloc, first of all. Very clean.
-What are you doing here?
-Really, it's rude enough being alive,
when no one wants you.
But showing up uninvited to a wedding...
-Fiona! I need to talk to you.
-Oh, now you wanna talk?
Well it's a little late for that.
So if you'll excuse me.
-But you can't marry him!
-And why not?
Because, because he's just marrying you
so he can be king.
-Outrageous! Fiona, don't listen to him.
-He's not your true love.
-What do you know about true love?
-Well, I ...I'm in...
Oh, this is precious.
The Ogre has fallen in love
with the princess.
Laugh.
Shrek. Is this true?
Who cares.
It's preposterous.
Fiona, my love, we gonna kiss away
for our happily ever after.
Now kiss me!
By night one way,
by day another.
I wanted to show you before.
Well. That explains a lot.
Oh. It's disgusting. Guards, guards.
I order you to get them out of my sight.
-Now! Get them! Get them, both!
-No!
This marriage is minding,
and that makes me king. See? See?
-Shrek!
-No.
-Don't just stand there, you dogs.
-Get out of my way.
No! Shrek!
-And as for you my wife.
-Fiona!
I'll have you locked back in that tower
for the rest of your days!
I will have order.
I will have potential.
I will have...
All right, nobody move!
I got a dragon here and I'm not afraid to use it.
I'm a donkey on the edge!
Celebrity marriages.
They never last, do they?
Go ahead Shrek.
-Fiona?
-Yes, Shrek?
I love you.
Really?
Really, really.
I love you too.
A time for true love's first kiss...
Fiona?
Fiona? Are you all right?
Yes. But I don't understand.
I'm supposed to be beautiful.
But you are beautiful.
I was hoping this would be a happy ending.
I thought love was only true in fairy tales
Meant for someone else but not for me
Love was out to get to me
That's the way it seems
Disappointment haunted all my dreams
And then I saw her face
Now I'm a believer
Not a trace
Of doubt in my mind
I'm in love
I'm a believer
I couldn't leave her if I tried
God bless us, everyone.
The End.
I can't breath. I can't breath.